my fellow Americans my first and highest
duty as president is to defend our great
country and the American people I swore
an oath to uphold the laws of our nation
and that is exactly what I will do all
Americans were rightly sickened and
revolted by the brutal death of George
Floyd my administration is fully
committed that for George and his family
justice will be served he will not have
died in vain but we cannot allow the
righteous cries and peaceful protestors
to be drowned out by an angry mob the
biggest victims of the rioting are
peace-loving citizens in our poorest
communities and as their president I
will fight to keep them safe I will
fight to protect you I am your president
of law and order and an ally of all
peaceful protesters but in recent days
our nation has been gripped by
professional anarchists violent mobs
arsonists looters criminals riders and
Tifa and others a number of state and
local governments have failed to take
necessary action to safeguard their
residents